- Conal Cochran, the owner
of the widely popular
Silver Shamrock Novelties Halloween
mask manufacturing company in 1982,
may have been born some
time around the 10th century
in Celtic Ireland.
While it is never made exactly clear
just how old Cochran is,
what is clear is that,
while he appears on the surface
to be a successful
60-something entrepreneur
who essentially runs the small town
of Santa Mira, California,
he is actually a sinister child murderer.
Cochran comes up with a devious plan
to sell hundreds of thousands
of rubber Halloween masks to children,
embedded with a chip
that will eventually kill
whoever is wearing it.
This is where I would say
that a plan to attack citizens
with microchips is a great plan
for a sci-fi horror premise,
because nobody would be dumb enough
to think that would actually happen,
but here we (piano tone) are.
(ominous music)
(man screaming)
He reveals himself to be
a studier of witchcraft,
intending to sacrifice as
many children as possible,
during the Festival of Samhain,
a holiday which eventually
became known in our culture
as Halloween.
Although in my culture,
that's just everyday.
To learn more about Conal Cochran,
and why he wants to sacrifice
hundreds of thousands of children
and if he can ever actually die,
stick around to the end of this video.
(ominous rock music)
Welcome to Horror History.
I've never met anyone named
Conal in my entire life.
The Halloween franchise has endured
over the last six decades,
thanks mostly in part to the popularity
of it's main antagonist.
Maybe you've heard of him.
But there is another
antagonist that I find just as,
if not more fascinating.
And I'm not talking about
Dr. Loomis circa 1989.
- What about your stepmother, Jamie?
- His initial roots could
date back thousands of years.
Cochran expresses
frustration with the fact
that most people today celebrate Halloween
without really understanding its origins.
- You don't really know
much about Halloween.
You thought no further
than the strange custom
of having your children wear masks
and go out begging for candy.
- He describes a time over 3000 years ago,
in what he refers to
as his old celtic lands
where the barriers would be down between
what he describes as
the real and the unreal.
He explains that this
was a time where the dead
could look in on the living,
referred to as the Festival of Samhain.
He explains that in the festival
they would have to make
human and animal sacrifices,
saying that the hills
ran red with the blood
of animals and children.
To completely understand
Cochran's motivation
for wanting to sacrifice an
entire generation of children,
we must take it back to the original
Pagan Festival of Samhain.
(suspenseful music)
The Festival of Samhain took
place around the 10th century,
and was one of four fire festival.
(upbeat music)
Not that kind of Fyre Festival.
That deserves it's own
episode of Horror History.
Samhain was considered
to be the most significant fire festival,
meant to usher in the
winter season's harvest.
It would take place
between the fall equinox
and the winter solstice,
which would fall from
the night of October 31st
through the morning of November 1st.
Hearth fires in family
homes were set to burn out
while the harvest was gathered.
The Samhain Festival was,
indeed, believed to be
a connection between the
living and the spirits
of those who had passed, where
a barrier would come down.
There was a fear that this
barrier could be breachable
by fairies, or other evil creatures
that could get through and inflict harm.
It was believed that the best way
to deflect these evil spirits
was by putting an offering
outside of individual homes.
While the offerings usually consisted
of parts of the harvest,
sometimes they would also include cattle.
If Cochran was around for the
original Samhain Festivals
then he would have been very familiar
with the practice of
putting out sacrifices
to ward off monsters and fairies.
However, the belief system
that Cochran subscribes
to gets much more specific
and instead of offering
crops or livestock,
involves the sacrifice of human children.
It seems maybe Cochran just
really doesn't like kids.
- I do love a good joke.
And this is the best ever,
a joke on the children.
- Yes, by killing them.
Cochran explains that
the last big festival
happened 3000 years ago.
When he describes it, he's
speaking in the first person,
suggesting that he was either there,
or he's just speaking
on behalf of his people.
- It was the start of the
year in our old celtic lands
and we'd be waiting in our
houses of wattles and clay.
- So, if that was the last
big festival and he was there,
then what was he doing
over the next 3000 years?
While Cochran's activity
from these festivals
up until the 20th century
is not completely clear,
we do know what he accomplished
within the last 300.
At some point, Cochran
established a company
known as Silver Shamrock Novelties.
I'm guessing the company
probably started in his
home country of Ireland,
then at some point moved
to Munich, Germany,
which he describes to be the birthplace
of this old woman knitting animatronic,
which was developed in 1785.
Silver Shamrock sold novelties.
These are usually gift items
that may appeal to someone
without having much, if any,
practical purpose.
He showcases some of his best creations
in what he calls The Hall of Fame.
Many of the toys that are
featured in the background
look like they may have been
made in the early 1900s.
Many of them are the kind that wind up
or require some kind of inner mechanics
to move and function.
Cochran is also said to be truly famous
for his practical jokes
or prank toys and items.
He's referred to as the all time genius
of the practical joke.
- He invented sticky toilet paper.
- Oh.
- Oh you must know.
The dead dwarf guy, the soft chain saw.
All his!
- From early on, it's obvious
that Cochran's target
demographic is children,
and he would shift his
focus over the years
to cater to whatever
was popular with kids.
But his interest in producing toys
had more than one ulterior motive.
(suspenseful music)
Being a producer of wind-up toys early on
allowed him to learn the engineering skill
to make his figures
move and seem life-like.
And with 100s of years of
practice, he mastered the art,
and became known for making the most
realistic looking masks on the market,
which is part of why they're so popular.
Put these two skills together,
and it becomes very easy
to see why Cochran's plans
and schemes are so threatening.
Cochran's factory workers,
as well as most citizens
in the town of Santa Mira,
seem to be under his complete control.
His men seem to have an almost
robotic level of obedience
towards him, but what
outsiders don't realize
is that this is because robotic
is exactly what they are.
Cochran set up an entire town of robots
to do all of his bidding,
both for his business,
his town, and for his
overall sacrificial plan.
Because of the fact that he
spent, likely, hundreds of years
developing the mechanisms for
his toys and figures to move,
he was able apply all of that knowledge
towards creating an entire town of robots.
- The surprising thing is
that the internal components
were quite simple to produce, really.
The outer features took
much longer to perfect
but then of course in the end,
it's just another form of mask making.
- The business arrived
at the small farming town
of Santa Mira, California
in 1945, after World War II.
It's no mistake that Cochran
chose to build his factory
far away from civilization,
where he could still launch
a successful business
but without a large population
being able to see exactly
what he was doing.
By then Cochran was already
described as being wealthy,
which means that he likely
already had a successful business
by this point.
The entire city is placed
under constant surveillance
and is locked down with
a six o'clock curfew,
allowing Cochran to do whatever he wants
under the cover of nightfall,
without having to worry
about the prying eyes
of the townspeople seeing what he's up to.
But how was Conal Cochran
able to keep himself alive for so long?
As he explains the history
of The Festival of Samhain,
he confirms that he
harnesses what most outsiders
would refer to as witchcraft,
but he simply sees it as a form of alchemy
that his people use to control the world.
This would actually make
sense, especially in 1982.
In the early 1980s, modern
Pagans known as Wiccans
started a revival of Samhain,
which was a ceremony
involving music and dance
called Witches' Balls.
A very not good title,
but at least they didn't
call them Cochran Balls.
However, in real life,
sacrificing children
was not part of the festival.
That's a pretty specific Cochran thing.
Maybe he was bullied by some
kids one time or something.
By 1982, the main focus of Silver Shamrock
was selling Halloween masks for kids,
but again, the masks were only
part of a much larger plan.
His real goal was to get
the kids wearing their masks
in front of a television screen,
where a hypnotic advertisement
would trigger a particle within the masks
and a beam would turn the kids' heads
into a series of bugs and snakes.
Making a TV program the center of his plan
fits in with what Cochran
has basically done all along:
follow the interests of the youth.
The 1980s were the
beginning of a golden age
for kids television programming.
Youth pop culture was driven by things
like Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and Transformers,
whose popularity revolved around cartoons
airing at the time.
Cochran has to commit
this sacrifice in 1982
due to the alignment of the planets
during that year's festival.
To pull this off, he
needs a magical artifact,
a monolith from the famous
prehistoric monument Stonehenge.
This is because each part of Stonehenge
is meant to represent one of
the 19 cycles of the moon.
Basically, the planetary alignment
is what allows the magic
inside the monument
to become active.
To give himself time to produce
and distribute masks containing
specs from the monument,
he steals it nine months
ahead of Halloween
in January of 1982.
The disappearance of
the Stonehenge monument
ends up being a mystery to the press.
From the public's perspective,
it just disappears overnight.
We don't know exactly how he
got such a massive artifact
out of England and into
the Western United States,
other than the fact that he
was aided by an army of robots
and still...
- We had a time getting it here.
- But we do know that his
evening lock-down of Santa Mira
probably made it easier to sneak
five tons of bluestone
back into his factory.
As the season of the witch approached,
he used his profits from years and years
of successful entrepreneurship
to fund a massive TV and
radio marketing campaign,
ensuring that his masks
would be the most popular
Halloween mask around kids.
♪ Eight more days till Halloween ♪
♪ Halloween ♪
♪ Silver Shamrock ♪
There seems to even be something hypnotic
about the commercial,
perhaps brainwashing them
into wanting these masks
more than any other.
It seems that Cochran is
able to test the potency
of the microchips inside of his masks,
and their response to
the hypnotic commercial
by arranging several TV
monitors using the same layout
as the stones in the Stonehenge monument.
When viewed from above,
the spacing of each television monitor
mimics the formation of Stonehenge
and the tops of the television monitors
connect with the stone and start to glow.
Throughout the course of the days
leading up to Halloween in 1982,
there is an advertisement
playing constantly
for the three Silver Shamrock masks
along with a big give away
that is supposedly going to
occur on TV on Halloween night.
Everything goes according to plan
until Cochran comes across a
man named Harry Grimbridge.
Harry was a shop owner local to California
who came to the factory to
pick up a new shipment of masks
in person on October 20th 1982.
Cochran would often give his top sellers
tours of the factory,
perhaps to help incentivize high sales.
Of course, he wouldn't show
them the most important part
of the mask making process,
what he calls final processing,
where the Stonehenge particle
microchip is implanted.
It seems that at some
point during his tour,
Mr. Grimbridge discovered
what really goes on
in final processing,
and made it his goal to
warn the public about it,
so Cochran sends one of his
androids to hunt him down,
with instructions to kill Grimbridge
and then self-destructs.
Of course this raises a lot of eyebrows
around the scene of the accident,
and eventually, on October 29th,
Mr. Grimbridge's doctor and his daughter
show up in Santa Mira looking for answers
about his untimely death.
(suspenseful music)
(ominous music)
They set themselves up at a local motel,
not yet knowing that this was a part
of Cochran's area of influence.
Seemingly everybody in
town is enamored with him,
as if he were someone like Walt Disney,
a sort of magical wonder.
Others, like Marge
Guttman who is also there
to pick up a shipment,
are annoyed with him and
his big business tactics.
Cochran's plan for dealing with
the doctor, Daniel Challis,
and the daughter, Ellie Grimbridge,
is to essentially sweep
everything under the rug,
and pretend that Harry picked up his order
and went on his way.
This is complicated, however,
when Marge Guttman gets
curious about the chip
she discovers on the back of
the Silver Shamrock trademark
attached to each mask, and
prods at it with a hairpin,
causing it to misfire,
blowing a hole through
her face with a laser
and causing bugs to come crawling out.
He sends his androids
to clean up the mess,
and Cochran himself is
even forced to come out
and access the situation
in the middle of the night,
where he meets Ellie and
Challis for the first time.
He assures them that Ms. Guttman
is gonna be sent to the factory,
where they supposedly have
excellent medical facilities,
but Challis, being a doctor
himself, isn't really buying it.
I mean why would a mask and toy factory
have its own hospital?
I mean, that's just asking for a lawsuit.
This isn't a great excuse
from Cochran to be honest.
And I think at this point,
he was just so close to Halloween,
and achieving his goal,
that he figured he
could tell them anything
and it would buy him enough time
to finish carrying out his plans.
He even tries to act
hospitable the next day
when they show up at the factory,
by inviting Challis and Ellie along
as he gives another tour,
this time to Buddy Kupfer and
his family, a mask store owner
and the number one Silver
Shamrock salesman in the country.
Before going on the tour,
Challis introduces himself and
Ellie as Mr. and Mrs. Smith,
which Cochran already knows is not true
because he's had an
eye on them for a while
and knows exactly who they
are and why they're here.
He wants to send them
away peacefully though,
so he makes a big spectacle
by offering to replace Mr.
Grimbridge's lost order for free,
hoping to distract them
from the possibility
that his factory had anything
to do with Harry's death.
- About the confusion over your order,
I'll just tell you one thing.
A replacement order is
being prepared for you
absolutely free, the whole thing's on me!
- He also has a big mural
of himself right behind him,
so between those two things,
and the fact that he
basically made himself
the mayor of a town of robots,
the man seems to have
a pretty fragile ego.
Perhaps he should have spent less time
congratulating himself and
more time hiding evidence,
because Ellie, at one point,
spots her father's car in plain sight
and immediately knows that this is where
he ran into trouble.
Before they can get out of
town and sound the alarm,
he has some of his ro-boys kidnap Ellie.
At this point, for reasons
that are still entirely unclear
to me, Cochran creates a
robot version of Ellie.
I guess if I'm gonna try to
put a reasoning behind this,
he did this as a backup plan,
to maybe try to stop Challis
if he's somehow able to escape the town
and try to warn the public
about the Silver Shamrock masks?
In any event, it's pretty impressive
that he's able to create
a perfect robot replica
of her in just one day.
He sends his bots after Challis too,
but he sneaks away out of their grasp
and goes to the factory
to try to save Ellie.
Cochran quickly learns of the intrusion
and goes to find one of his androids
has been dismantled by Challis
and his knitting woman
animatronic decapitated.
This time, when he sees his intruder,
he doesn't bother with entertaining
the false name that he gave last time.
- Ah, Mr. Challis.
- Where is Ellie?
- Mrs. Smith.
- He takes Challis prisoner overnight.
So the next day is Halloween,
and Cochran takes a moment to appreciate
and breathe in that fresh autumn air.
He knows that this is his big day.
And he's about to gain an
immeasurable amount of power.
He takes Challis down to
the final processing area.
Now I know evil monologues
where the bad guy explains his entire plan
before it's too late for the
hero to do anything about it
are a common movie trope.
Because the audience needs
to understand what's going on
and that's the easy way to do it,
so that's probably why he
essentially reveals everything
to Dr. Challis.
But on the other hand, I'm
here to analyze his character,
so let's look at why he
might have done this.
I imagine that the man
lived a very lonely life.
He secludes himself up to a small town
in Northern California,
where he's surrounded entirely by robots
with very little personality.
He's been alive for
probably thousands of years.
All of his original friends and family
have most likely passed at this point,
and if any of them have
survived like he has,
I imagine that they're all
the way back in Ireland.
Cochran seems to be a classic case
of the lonely at the top CEO.
This probably explains
why he puts on the act
of being overly hospitable
when people come
to pick up orders,
and why he enjoys giving
tours of the factory.
The man is starved for human interaction,
so he decides to get
the most out of Challis
before killing him, by
explaining his entire plan.
That probably also explains
why he remains so friendly
with the man who's trying to
expose him, and take him down.
He even shows Challis a
demonstration of the power bestowed
inside of each Silver
Shamrock Halloween masks
when the planets are aligned properly.
The Kupfer family, who he had
given the tour the day before,
is placed inside of a test room.
And a version of the Silver
Shamrock advert is played,
causing the young Kupfer boy to pass out
as his insides are turned into
a horde of crawling insects
and aggressive serpents.
He leaves Challis tied up in
another test room that evening,
and places a mask over his face,
planning to let the
Silver Shamrock commercial
do the rest of the work.
- And
Happy Halloween.
- Cochran goes back to his command center
at final processing,
where he makes a few
last minute phone calls,
and tells someone that
the Halloween giveaway
is just gonna be a fun
thank you for his customers,
when he's informed of a camera malfunction
in Challis's room.
He sends his drones in,
where they discover that
their prisoner has escaped,
but he shows no concern,
because he's already got a plan B.
He simply watches as Challis goes to save
what he thinks is Ellie,
but is actually robo-Ellie,
who is programmed to kill
him if he manages to escape.
However, Dr. Challis doesn't
act as Cochran expected him to.
Instead of leaving the factory,
he sneaks back into the
final processing room,
and starts playing the
commercial internally.
He sees Challis scurrying away,
and sends his androids after him,
as he climbs up above the ceiling rafters,
where he dumps an entire
box full of mask trademarks
down onto the factory floor
while the commercial blasting through
the television monitors.
This activates each of the buttons,
and the part of Stonehenge
residing in the factory.
The interference causes all
of the robots in the area
to malfunction and fall to the ground.
Yet still, Cochran doesn't seem concerned,
thrown off or even frustrated
at his plans being thwarted.
In fact, he seems quite the opposite.
He gives Challis a slow clap.
As he does so, the stone zaps him
and he seemingly turns to stone himself,
which looks like either
something out of a nightmare
or something out of a hilarious meme,
then he completely disappears.
He doesn't burn up or
turn into a swarm of bugs
like the victims that
we had previously seen.
There's still some debate
as to what happened here.
Did Cochran use the witchcraft
that he was so familiar with
to teleport himself out of the factory?
Or was the beam coming directly
from the Stonehenge monument itself
so powerful that it essentially
zapped him out of existence?
Personally, I read this as
the death of Conal Cochran,
but to be honest, we'll probably
never find out for sure,
since it's been 40 years
with no more Halloween spin-off movies,
and the great Dan O'Herlihy,
who played Conal Cochran in
the film is no longer with us.
That being said, I'd
definitely be in favor of them
making a movie called Halloween III 2,
so if you're watching this Universal,
let's make that happen.
That will conclude today's lesson,
but let me know what
other Halloween characters
you'd like to see covered
here on Horror History.
Subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week,
ring that deathbell
and make sure you select all notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
(upbeat music)